vamos a seguir creando herramientas para
atender nuestra caja de herramientas
completa de los números complejos
recuerden que un número complejo z tiene
la forma a más b y donde a y b son
números reales
y es el número imaginario a raíz de
menos 1 es muy importante que no olviden
que cuando nosotros estamos hablando de
números complejos estamos hablando de un
número que tiene una parte real y una
parte imaginaria la suma de una parte
real de una parte imaginaria por lo
tanto en este número complejo z
va a ser mi parte real y ve y es mi
parte imaginaria y a pesar de que sea un
número real al multiplicarlo por el
número imaginario y raíz de menos 1 se
convierte en que ve y es un número
imaginario y ahora sí ya que tenemos una
parte real y una parte imaginaria z va a
ser un número complejo pero hay que
tener cuidado para dejarlo más claro voy
a decir que si yo tengo una función de
la parte real de mi número complejo ésta
va a ser a y si yo tomara la función de
mi parte imaginaria del complejo zeta
esta va a ser b es decir el número
qué hace la escala con mi parte
imaginaria ojo tomen en cuenta que como
vimos en el vídeo pasado la función de
la parte imaginaria de z es de solamente
b es decir a que el número que hace la
escala con la parte imaginaria sive
aumenta la parte imaginaria va a
aumentar su vez disminuye la parte
imaginaria va a disminuir tengan cuidado
solamente es cuestión de recordar que
cuando nosotros tenemos la función de la
parte imaginaria de z es de aquel número
que está multiplicando a y en mi número
complejo mientras que en mi número
complejo como aparece un número real p x
y es un número imaginario pero bueno de
cualquier manera nosotros habíamos visto
esto en el vídeo pasado así que vamos a
empezar a ver lo que tenemos que ver
este vídeo en este video se llama
complejos conjugados por lo tanto voy a
definir lo que es el conjugado de un
número complejo voy a decir que el
conjugado de mi número complejo va a ser
z con una barra encima o con otros
autores lo llaman set asterisco y éste
va a ser a menos
es decir es lo mismo que el complejo
original solamente que estoy cambiando
de signo la parte imaginaria voy a ver
esto con una gráfica para que quede
mucho más claro en esta gráfica voy a
poner como el eje de las equis a la
parte real de mi complejo y como eje de
las 10 a la parte imaginaria por lo
tanto si z es un vector entonces va a
tener como parte real aa y como parte
imaginaria a b fíjense que este vector z
que soy pintado de amarillo tiene en
parte real y ve en parte imaginaria
ahora qué pasará con el conjugado pues
bien la parte real se va a mantener
constante es invariante sigue siendo a
sin embargo la parte imaginaria va a
cambiar de signo en lugar de ser b iba a
ser menos b y mi vector va a seguir
siendo el mismo solamente que esta vez
en lugar de ir hacia arriba irá hacia
abajo
quiero que observen que la longitud de
mi vector es la misma lo único que
cambia es la dirección o dicho de una
manera distinta es el mismo vector
solamente que está reflejado con
respecto al eje de las equis pero bueno
es hora de que veamos propiedades muy
interesantes que tienen los complejos
conjugados
por ejemplo la suma de complejos
conjugados que sería la suma de
complejos conjugados gráficamente es la
suma de dos vectores mi vector que tengo
de amarillo que era z y a éste le voy a
sumar un vector de morado que la zeta
conjugado y la suma de estos dos
vectores me va a dar un punto en niegue
de la parte real z maceta conjugado es
lo mismo que a massa es decir este punto
que yo tengo aquí es un número real
igual a todos y lo podemos probar
también de una manera algebraica si yo
tengo acepta que es a mí ya éste le sumo
se ha conjugado que es a menos b y
entonces yo obtendría que más b y más a
menos b y pues b y menos pedir se va y
me queda dos veces a dicho de otra forma
mucho más elegante yo sé que se está más
cerca conjugado lo voy a poner aquí es
igual a dos veces la función de la parte
real de mi complejo es decir dos veces a
muy bien para terminar esta propiedad en
resumidas cuentas si yo tengo un
complejo cualquiera
su conjugado siempre voy a obtener dos
veces la parte real pero bueno cambiamos
a otra propiedad muy importante acerca
de los complejos conjugados se utiliza
mucho en la división voy a verlo con un
caso particular supongamos que yo tengo
1 + 2 y que es un complejo ya éste le lo
divido entre 4 5 y que también es un
número complejo suene un poco lógico
decir que un número complejo entre un
número complejo me va a dar un número
complejo pero bueno con un cuadro
resolver esto para resolver una división
entre números complejos voy a
multiplicar por 1 pero porque uno por un
uno muy especial uno no tramposo ni uno
va a ser el complejo conjugado del
complejo que divide es decir del
denominador ahora sí estoy yo multiplico
por 45 y entre 45 ahí que es 1 voy a
poder resolver esta división y como lo
voy a hacer pues bueno es solamente una
multiplicación algebraica primero voy a
multiplicar mis dos complejos que están
en el numerador 1 por 45 y pues es 45
ahí aquí no hay mucho que hacer
y 2 por 4 es 8 y 2 y por 5 y es 10 y
cuadrada pero recuerden que y cuadrada
es menos 1 entonces esto es menos 10 ya
esto hay que dividirlo entre 4 - 5 y por
4 5 y es una diferencia de cuadrados
está muy fácil de hacer esto es el
cuadrado en el primer número o sea 4 por
4 es 16 lo voy a notar aquí 16 menos
el cuadrado del segundo pero aquí aquí
me falta algo aquí está mal porque le
era cinco y no cuatro y perdón perdón
aquí voy a poner cinco y ahora sí otra
vez vamos a hacer la parte de abajo que
es una diferencia de cuadrados les
quiero pedir una disculpa porque siempre
me equivoco en todos los vídeos es que
mi mente va más rápido de lo que va el
vídeo y empiezo a divagar y entonces
siempre comento errores de dedo pero
bueno ahora sí vamos a hacerlo
es una diferencia de cuadrados entonces
me queda 4 x 4 que es 4 al cuadrado lo
voy a notar acá ya esto hay que restarle
el cuadrado del segundo o sea menos 5 y
al cuadrado y esto quién es cuatro menos
diez pues es muy fácil de hacer
10 6 y 5 y 8 y es lo mismo que 13 y ya
esto lo voy a dividir entre 4 al
cuadrado que es 16 menos 5 y al cuadrado
o sea 25 y cuadrada pero como es
cuadrada es negativo entonces obtengo
menos 25 y con este menos me da más 16
más 25 es 41 bien menos 6 13 y entre 41
esto lo puedo escribir de otra manera lo
puedo escribir como menos seis entre 41
más 13 entre 41 por iu y que creen esto
es un número complejo si yo he vivido un
número complejo entre otro número
complejo obtengo un número complejo y
ten se cuenta que podemos resolver esta
división porque podríamos multiplicar a
un complejo por su conjugado es decir un
complejo por su conjugado es lo mismo
que quedara complejo el complejo es
además b y entonces lo mismo que a más b
y que multiplica a menos b
y dicho de otra manera esto es una
diferencia de cuadrados que obtengo el
cuadrado del primero y ya esto hay que
quitarle el cuadrado del segundo
pero esto es lo mismo que a cuadrada y
después tengo b elevado al cuadrado es
de cuadrada negativo por menos pues me
va a quedar más cuadrada o dicho otra
manera esto es lo mismo que la magnitud
del complejo elevado al cuadrado espero
que en este vídeo le se ha quedado claro
lo útiles que pueden ser de los
complejos conjugados por ejemplo en
operaciones como la división de con
números complejos de cualquier manera
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo